uh about 10 years ago i used to
i guess try and get away from theory a
little bit more than i do now now i vary
my approach uh quite
quite a bit more i gotten
my preparation is better
as i have
very good people working with me while
then i was work mostly working on my own
i'm still not like
a top of opening expert but
it's still very different from from what
it used to be in the sense that i do
these days well especially a couple of
years ago but still these days i still
do sometimes
um uh get a get an advantage from
or a huge advantage from from the
opening uh which i didn't really used to
to do back in the days yeah well i'd
certainly worked with uh with people uh
people before
but
after i stopped working with gary in
2000
early 2010 um
until the candidates in 2013 i was
mostly
mostly working on on my own which was
you know
it was hugely um
successful but i think not particularly
because of openings probably
despite it and looking back i think um
it was it was um a good thing because i
i learned how to
to to win without
without openings but i think it's been
it's been good for me also
more recently that i've been able to
to have a more balanced approach